old friends uh zingman Freud and Carl
Jung so how vast is this uh
landscape of the unconscious mind the
power and the scope of the dictator is
uh is it only dark there
is it uh some light is there some love
the vast majority of what's happening in
your head you're unaware of so in a
literal sense the unconscious the
aspects of your mind that you're not
conscious of is the overwhelming
majority that but that's just true in a
literal engineering sense your mind is
doing lots of low-level things and you
just can't be consciously aware of all
that low-level stuff but there's plenty
of room there for lots of things you're
not aware of
but can we try to shine a light at the
things we're unaware of
specifically now again staying with the
philosophical psychology side for a
moment
you know can you shine the light in the
youngin Shadow can you what what's going
on there what is this machine like like
what what level of thoughts are
happening there is it uh something that
could we can even interpret if we
somehow could visualize it is it
something that's human interpretable or
is it just a kind of chaos of like
monitoring different systems in the body
making sure you're happy making sure
you're um fed all those kind of basic
forces that form abstractions on top of
each other and they're not introspective
at all we humans are social creatures
plausibly being social is the main
reason we have these unusually large
brains therefore most of our brain is
devoted to being social
and so the things we are very obsessed
with and constantly paying attention to
are how do I look to others
what would others think of me if they
knew these various things they might
learn about me so that's close to being
fundamental to what it means to be human
is caring what others think right to to
be trying to present a story that would
be okay for what other things but we're
very constantly thinking what do other
people think so let me ask you this
question then about you Robin Hansen who
many places sometimes for fun sometimes
as a basic statement of principle likes
to disagree with with the majority of
people think
um so how do you explain
um how are you self-deceiving yourself
in this task
and how are you being self how's your
like why is the dictator manipulating
you inside your head to be self-critical
like there's Norms why do you want to
stand out
or in this way why do you want to
challenge the Norms in this way almost
by definition I can't tell you what I'm
deceiving myself about
the more practical strategy that's quite
feasible is to ask about what are
typical things that most people disease
themselves about and then to own up to
those particular things sure what's
what's a good one so for example I can
very much acknowledge that I would like
to be well thought of yes that I would
be seeking uh attention and glory and uh
praise yes from my intellectual work and
that that would be a major agenda
driving my intellectual attempts
um
so you know if there were topics that
other people would find less interesting
I might be less interested in those for
that reason for example I might want to
find topics whether people are
interested and I might want to
um go for the glory of finding a big
Insight rather than a small one
and maybe one that was especially
surprising
that's also of course consistent with
some more ideal concept of what an
intellectual should be
but most intellectuals are relatively
risk-averse they are in some local
integral tradition and they are adding
to that and they are staying conforming
to these sort of usual assumptions and
usual accepted beliefs and practices of
a particular area
so that they can be accepted in that
area and you know treat it as part of
the community
um but you might think for the purpose
of the larger intellectual project of
understanding the world better
people should be less eager to just add
a little bit to some tradition and they
should be looking for what's neglected
between the major traditions and major
questions they should be looking for
assumptions maybe we're making that are
wrong they should be looking at ways
things that are very surprising like
things that would be
you would have thought a prior and
likely that once you are convinced of it
you find that to be very important and
uh and a big update right so
um
you could say that
um one motivation I might have is less
motivated to be sort of comfortably
accepted into some particular
intellectual community and more willing
to just go for these
more fundamental long shots that should
be very important if you could find them
which would if if you can find them
would get you attempt appreciated uh
respect across a larger number of people
across the longer time span of History
right so like maybe this the small local
community will say you suck all right
you must conform but the larger
Community will see the Brilliance of you
breaking out of the cage of the small
Conformity into a larger cage it's
always a bigger there's always a bigger
cage and then you'll be remembered by
more